m
le néracais le centre français de
recherche aérospatiale donc c'est un
établissement public qui est vraiment
dédié à la recherche dans le domaine de
l'aéronautique du spatial et de la
défense et qui rassemble un ensemble de
compétences et de moyens expérimentaux
assez unique en france vraiment orientée
vers la satisfaction des besoins
notamment notre industrie nous sommes un
établissement qui est le résultat d'une
vraie volonté politique de l'état de se
doter d'un instrument pour justement ses
activités de recherche de défense et
nous sommes d'ailleurs pas ce titre
placé sous la tutelle unique du ministre
de la défense
nous sommes un des premiers occupants de
ce plateau puisque nous sommes implantés
ici depuis 1952
quelques exemples de réalisations et de
travaux très très récent bien tout ce
qu'on fait dans le domaine de l'art de
la propulsion des avions
pour le futur avec des coopérations
notamment avec le motoriste safran qui
vient d'installer un centre de recherche
qui s'appelle safran tech sur le plateau
est par ailleurs nous avons une grosse
activité autour du futur de la défense
et nous sommes présents je dirais dans
dans toutes les grandes fonctions
stratégiques qui ont été identifiés dans
les livres blancs successifs de la
défense nous préparons clairement le
long et le très long terme pour l'onera
et je dirais pour tous les partenaires
qui sont présents sur ce plateau qu'il
s'agisse de centres de recherche comme
nous d'universités d'écoles de grandes
écoles en particulier est naturellement
de l'industrie le plateau de saclay
saclay et palaiseau c'est vraiment une
aventure qui ne fait que commencer et
beaucoup d'industriels vont rejoindre
progressivement le plateau pour vraiment
créer j'irai des modes de coopération et
de partenariat nouveau où on va faire de
l'innovation où on va pas simplement
lire et faire de la la recherche et de
la technologie mais où on va chercher à
convertir beaucoup plus rapidement des
avancées de la recherche en produits
ayant géré une valeur économique et
ayant des conséquences très directe par
exemple sur l'emploi qui est un sujet
qui concerne véritablement tout le monde
l'association des entreprises delta de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines soutient le
projet de cluster aéronautique
c'est un projet de développement
économique important pour le territoire
nous allons une grande entreprise qui
contribue à ce projet comme airbus avec
des sujets très innovant qui vont
permettre d'associer à la fois la
technologie issue d'un grand groupe
et puis les apports sur de l'innovation
l'issue de pme du territoire qui vont
pouvoir contribuer tessa sur un projet
qui se développera sur l'aéroport de
toussus-le-noble autour de l'avion
électrique ifan le projet de cluster
aéronautique s'intègre dans les projets
de paris-saclay donc nous sommes au
coeur du territoire de l'eau yen va
faire partie des projets industriels qui
mêle à la fois développement économique
mais également des aspects recherche
innovation et qui pourront toucher
également des établissements
d'enseignement et de recherche du
territoire comme l'estaca il ya
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines